make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing out and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
you never close your eyes anymore when I
kiss your lips hello everyone how's
everybody doing
Oh Hall & Oates you guys were amazing is
everybody doing good I know it's crazy
out there in the world I know everything
seems like it's crazy and it's just full
of pandemonium but I am here to cheer
you up because in this video we are back
once again with our what-if series where
we make up stories and in this one we
aren't answering the question what if
Bannos found the anti-life equation so I
think the first thing we have to do
before we get into any of the story is
go over the question of what exactly is
the anti-life equation so the anti-life
equation was originally conceived of by
Jack Kirby when he left Marvel to go to
DC and created his fourth world universe
which told the stories of the new gods
like mr. miracle Orion and big Barda as
well as their nemesis Darkseid who of
course will go on to become one of the
most prominent DC villains so the
anti-life equation was introduced by
Jack Kirby and would allow those who
possessed it to gain control over any
sentient being and the desire to find
the equation has basically been the
motivating factor behind most of what
Darkseid has done since his introduction
now just to address the elephant in the
room we should acknowledge that when
Thanos was created his design was
heavily inspired by dark side with
creator jim Starlin admitting that he
changed Thanos is designed to be a
ripoff of Darkseid at the request of
editor Roy Thomas and so while it might
seem a little too obvious to just take
the thing the dark sides always looking
for and half the annals find it I
actually think it makes sense within the
broader scope of Thanos his character so
as you probably know
Thanos is obsessed with winning the
affection of mistress death and so it's
that in that he seeks out the Cosmic
Cube and the infinity gems because he
believed that they would give him the
power to cause enough death and
destruction to impress her now within
that framework if Thanos were to learn
of the existence of something called the
anti-life equation well what better way
to impress death after all what is the
antithesis of life but death so we won't
spend a lot of time focusing on how
Thanos figures out the anti-life
equation we'll just suffice it to say
Betty learns of it and being an
individual of great and
like in scientific knowledge he figures
it out oh what's vastly more interesting
than how he figures out what the
equation is is what he does with it
once he does figure it out and what I
think you would do is travel from planet
to planet infecting the inhabitants with
the anti-life equation in order to take
control of their minds and build an army
now the rationale for this would be
twofold first he knows that the more
planets he goes to the more attention
he's going to attract from those who
will want to stop them
secondly the anti-life equation
basically kills the will to live of
anyone in infects to the point that they
basically embrace death and so following
a madman into battle where you'll
basically serve as cannon fodder it
seems like a great way to accomplish
that it isn't too long before we see
that Thanos is prediction is correct as
a distress signal was sent out from one
of the planets that he goes to and is
received by the guardians of the galaxy
who respond to the call now when they
arrive on the planet's surface and they
realize that it's Thanos they're going
up against they know they don't have
much of a chance in winning on their own
but they prepare for a fight as Drax and
Gamora are always out for revenge on the
mad Titan now as you'd expect it doesn't
go too well for the guardians of the
galaxy Thanos has already amassed a
great number for his army in addition to
already being far too powerful for the
Guardians even by himself and so when
the battle is over Thanos has managed to
infect all the guardians with the
equation except for star-lord who
manages to escape before being infected
and so angered the star-lord had got
away uninfected Thanos valves that he
will make star-lord pay by setting his
sights on his home planet meaning that
Thanos and his army are heading toward
Earth
so star-lord immediately sends a message
to anyone that could feasibly be of any
help letting them know of the army that
Thanos has built and the fact that he's
able to bring anyone that comes into
contact with him under his control and
so the call is answered by virtually any
hero you can think of the Avengers the
Fantastic Four all the cosmic heroes
like beta ray bill Nova and Silver
Surfer and even the x-men who are
typically just chilling on cacoa
devoting all their time to building a
mutant nation and not really caring
about anything else in the world but
then getting mad when the world stops
caring about them it is kind of a weird
attitude to take right like I don't care
about the world but I care about what it
thinks about me the x-men are like the
ultimate angsty people but anyway we see
some unlikely heroes thrown into the mix
right Doctor Doom who despite being a
villain doesn't really want to see
phantoms come to light
and infect his subjects so of course he
agrees to help the planning process of
how to deal with this impending invasion
by Thanos and his army does hit a snag
when the heroes realized that even
though they have a lot of firepower at
their disposal many of the people
they'll be fighting are not willing
combatants but are only there because
they've been brainwashed by the
anti-life equation for this reason the
heroes feel uneasy about killing them
and so they try to devise a strategy
whereby they can defeat Thanos
but spare the lives of his soldiers and
so when Thanos finally shows up the
heroes trying to cordon off as many of
his brainwashed soldiers inside force
fields created by Susan storm and as
they take the fight to Thanos the most
powerful telepaths among them Charles
Xavier Jean Grey and Emma Frost try to
probe the minds of the infected and
purge them of the equation but they have
no success whatsoever as the effects of
the equation are too strong even for
their combined telepathic prowess and so
the magic wielders like Doctor Strange
dr. doom and the Scarlet Witch try to
find a solution to breaking Thanos as
control by drawing on the mystic arts
but again it's to no avail as the
anti-life equation is not magical in
nature and so finally it becomes clear
that the strategy the heroes have put in
place is not going to be successful as
Thanos is able to infect the citizens of
earth with the equation adding millions
of humans to his army in an instant and
so as the hero scramble to keep the
humans safe they're unable to direct
enough of their firepower to Thanos and
as a result he's able to infect several
of the heroes as well turning them
against their former allies now at this
point things are looking pretty bleak
for the good guys here and it looks like
Thanos is going to make good on his
threat to conquer the earth but before
he's able to claim a total victory the
Marvel heroes get some help from an ally
that they've never seen before but we
know this guy is Kyle Rayner who's in
possession of the white Lantern ring as
it turns out in the DC Universe there is
an opposing force to the anti-life
equation which is known believe it or
not as the life equation and that force
is extremely powerful and is even
capable of remaking reality itself and
although the life equation varies in its
nature based on who is writing one
version of the equation is rooted in the
emotional spectrum and that's the
version were using here because honestly
it's the most interesting so at one
point how Rader basically created seven
white lantern rings which when he
brought together with his ring can
activate the life equation
and so I think that will be interesting
here is that Kyle basically picks seven
Marvel heroes to give these rings to and
he bases his decision on his ability to
detect each of the seven emotions of the
emotional spectrum of these heroes and I
think this would be a cool moment
because one thing that fans always love
to do is figure out who for Marvel
Comics would fit in with each Lantern
Corps and so this gives us a chance to
do that and while there are obviously
multiple candidates that would be great
for each emotion we have to actually
make some decisions because there are
only seven rings so for the emotion of
love Susan storm is chosen due to her
unwavering devotion to her family and
especially her children Franklin and
Valyria
for compassion we're gonna go with
someone who embodies the emotion not
someone who needs to be brainwashed into
feeling compassion as we see sometimes
in DC so we're gonna go with Jean Dre
because of the empathic nature of her
telepathic powers for avarice or greed
well dr. doom is chosen because you know
he's Doctor Doom do we need to explain
any more than that to embody rage the
natural Pig would be the Hulk but since
he's off doing his immortal Hawke stuff
and basically wants to save the world by
eliminating humanity he's gonna sit this
one out but she Hulk is a member of the
tour Avengers team and his Jess's
rage-fueled as the hope really Ryan Ryan
wrote this script my writer Ryan wrote
the script she-hulk
she-hulk sucks nobody wants to see
she-hulk with a lantern ring you know
we're gonna give a Red Lantern ring to
we are gonna give a Red Lantern ring to
Magneto because of how pissed off
magneto is just as a guy right so like
Wolverine is chosen as the avatar of
fear because of his ability to instill
fear in others due to having one of the
highest kill counts in the Marvel
Universe now to embody hope who else
could be picked but Captain America and
finally to personify willpower and Kyle
Rayner selects the current leader of the
Avengers black panther and gives him his
own white Lantern ring stating that the
Rings will work more efficiently if
they're wielded by individuals who have
an emotional connection to one another
and since no one here knows Kyle he
won't have a connection with anyone and
so with these seven individuals working
together the white lantern rings
activate the life equation and
hold on the infected is broken and those
who fought on his behalf
end up turning against him the heroes
use the White Lantern rings to rewrite
reality so that those infected are
returned to their homes and have no
memory of being possessed by the
anti-life equation and the actions a and
wouldn we took in the service of Thanos
and so they also wipe all knowledge of
the equation from thousands mind the
White Lantern rings are then returned to
Kyle Rayner but he leaves one of them in
the possession of Black Panther for
safekeeping in Avengers Mountain telling
him that as part of his arrangement Kyle
may call upon him for assistance if it's
needed within his universe so yeah
that's how I think this would play out I
think was a good call for us to remove
the the Red Lantern ring from shield
I'm sorry she-hulk but you're just not
really that interesting of a character
ah now here's a here's a funny thing
like vanos would almost totally destroy
the entire universe right but we did get
to see some Marvel characters wielding
White Lantern rings and then we leave
the door open for more crossover down
the road by leaving a white Lantern ring
in the Marvel Universe and with Doctor
Doom having experienced the power of
wielding a white Lantern ring and
knowing that the one that was left was
with T'Challa I feel like there's not
much doubt that he would eventually make
a play for it and if he's able to get it
that would open the door to even more
trouble for the Marvel Universe but let
me know what you guys think but I think
it was a cool idea I think this was a
really really cool what if story ah let
me know what you guys think down in the
comment section if you are new here to
comment explain Mitch you guys with the
sub button to become part of the world
for if you guys enjoyed this video make
sure you drop a like and I will catch
you all later Bruce
[Music]
[Music]